so one of the things that you've done a
fantastic job I think teaching people
over the years is how money in the
economy works right everything from the
the cashflow quadrant of just get the
hell out of the left side and get on the
right side of the thing et cetera you've
literally educated millions of people
for those that don't understand it the
stimulus I think is there's two
components to it that crack me up
right and I want Europeans the first is
the $1,200 check I just call that that's
the bribe
that's the bribe for social to avoid
social unrest now we're gonna give you
guys 1,200 bucks everybody shut up and
you know we're trying to help you
and if things get really bad we
basically give you $1,200 and you're
good which isn't actually helpful to
majority of people right but then you
also get the stimulus to the
corporations which you know you've
highlighted it's just socialism for
corporations or socialism for the rich
so maybe talk a little bit about what
exactly you mean by socialism for
corporations or for the rich well I
think this is a great book it's a big
book but you know get the book is called
the creature from Jekyll Island by my
friend Tierra Griffith and this is I
think it's a 1996 book came out and he
wrote in there bailout is the name of
the game so the feds only purpose and
the Fed is not a bank
it's a cartel owned by the richest
people in the planet which will never
see their and their this guy Grunch
this is Buckman so for brunch stands for
gross Universal cash lights so the guys
at home the feared control the world not
the Fed but they control the world so
once you understand that because okay
now I'd better start doing something
different so what the Fed what the the
creature does it drops the world into
this crisis and a pendant pendant the
pandemic is probably real but then you
get so desperate you'll take the money
it's communism yeah see what happens
what Edward Griffin says in a creature
from Jekyll Island was that when Marx
attempted to bring communism to America
was Americans are too tough the American
spirit is too strong so what Griffin is
saying here what the what whoever what
fuller calls grudge had to do or marks
had to do was introduce socialism first
so the way you introduce socialism is
called Social Security and all that the
happiest crisises the depression you
know 9/11 this one over here and people
get so desperate
Rickards are saying the same thing you
know I rode through Rouen and all that
we get so desperate we'll take anything
and so they're gonna give you this
thousand dollar check to but first have
to bust your spirit and that's what I
was saying to my friend you know send
your kid even to the Coast Guard let me
do something you know grow up so you get
so just but you take that check next
stop is communism
so he goes capitalism socialism
communism and you can see it right now
because they're gonna bail Boeing out
guess what the feds gonna take Clark
ownership a Boeing that's communism
you'll study economics idiots up there I
mean that's communism so it they bust
our spirits Oh $1,200
the government cuz I don't have a job
well that's the that's the same exact
number that did in Hong Kong not too
long ago you know those guys are rioting
in the streets they gave twelve hundred
dollars also and the branch by Bucky
fuller gross Universal Cash ice beams VR
money all systems that's why there's no
financial education in schools and
that's why today I'm doing better than
ever I'm making money hand over fist you
know my biggest problems they can't get
enough inventory my cash flow game it's
a good problem not complaining but we
have to pay extra air freight I'm in
know what stuff like this stuff but it's
a good problem but we were prepared for
it yeah the witness he went to school
you're not yeah I think part of what
you're really highlighting here is this
whole idea that anytime a crisis occurs
it's an opportunity to grab
civil liberties personal freedom and
also economically and the part to me
that I don't understand why people are
missing this but I think you've done a
great job highlighting it is the
socialism for the rich and the
corporation's that's gonna happen
whether you and I like it or not it's
gonna happen and so that's just you know
what it is but the cost for the bottom
50% of Americans when they when the
stimulus occurs right that the
devaluation of the currency and kind of
all of the things that I think the gold
bugs and and the bitcoiners have been
yelling and screaming about for years
it's here it's happening right before
our eyes and the sad part is that the
people who get hurt the most are the
people who are the most vulnerable right
the people who actually need the most
help they get hurt because they're
sitting in cash they have no real assets
they're getting paid you know hourly
wages that aren't adjusted for inflation
etc and there's nothing they can really
do other than educate themselves which
is when you spent the last you know
twenty-something plus years doing for
people I think well look at the worst
part about it too they send their kids
to college was the universities and they
load up the student loan debt and that
that occurred in 2009 you know when
Obama took he basically said to the
banks look you land these kids all this
money and defend what the Treasury will
back him up and now those kids are
desperate that's why that's why I wrote
Rich Dad Poor Dad back in 97 I created
my cash flow board game it says our
schools don't teach us anything about
money but that's what this book was
hearing crunch was giant it's not an
accident grunts hands for gross
Universal cash wise and we can see it
today that's what this book is saying
we'd let we're shifting from capitalism
to socialism yeah Bernie Sanders said a
OSE and the rest of those cartoons
running and then when they bailout
Boeing which is in trouble anyway but
they're going to take a percentage
ownership so yeah it goes some
capitalism socialism communism and
that's what this guy was saying that's
what creature from saying and that's
what rickards is saying and the road to
ruin this is not a mistake
and we've been warning people all these
years and they still send their kids to
college and learn nothing about money
but they learned that fragile